ah Suicide Squad is finally here from
writer director David Ayer the man who
brought us movies like training day yes
sabotage hmm and if you guys know
anything about this movie or these
characters you know that it is an
assemblage of the baddies this is like
the Justice League of the bad guys
Viola Davis wants to recruit these
people to go out into the city to defeat
this thing that's wreaking havoc in the
middle of the city and the beam is
shooting up to the sky and it's a big
deserted city and there's a battle so
you know it's it's a comic book movie or
the new Ghostbusters that happens a lot
in movies is what I'm saying now I was
really excited for this movie not just
because I enjoy the comics and I love
these characters but because of the cast
involved and the director I think
training day is an excellent movie and I
liked end of watch maybe even a little
bit more I think David Ayer's super
talented so I was so excited to see what
he could bring to this universe because
not only is he directing but he's also
writing so that's a big creative talent
working with all these awesome
characters and a plethora of great
source material we'll talk more about
that in a minute let's talk about pros
first Will Smith as Deadshot I really
like this character he's one of the very
few people in this team that has given
any bit of characterization he has a
daughter you'll learn a little bit more
about his past there's a really integral
scene involving another DC Comics
character that gives him some humanity
and it makes you feel for him I also
thought he was very entertaining and a
lot of his jokes hit that's another
positive this movie is more lighthearted
it does have humor and it feels like the
characters are having fun Margot Robbie
as Harley Quinn she was exactly like the
animated series character she did a
great job capturing that character's
unhinged insanity well also similar to
Deadshot having just a small thorough
line of humanity peeking out of it the
first 20 to 30 minutes or so were pretty
good although there is a lot of people
telling us about characters there's a
big difference between us watching
something happen to a character and
another character that we don't know
just coming in and saying here's what
you need to know about this person
because we don't really have any time to
set up these characters let's just get
to the big Beeman
sky for instance if you had never heard
of Superman before or he was a more
obscure comic book character and he
comes on screen and somebody says this
is Superman his planet was destroyed he
has no family feel bad for him
that's essentially most of the
characterization we get for the members
of the Suicide Squad
except for Deadshot and Harley Quinn and
a lot of their stories are told through
excessive flashbacks the brief
appearances by Batman were awesome Ben
Affleck once again looks amazing as this
character and I want to see Ben Affleck
as Batman in a great movie also Jai
Courtney was not awful he was actually
pretty good as Captain Boomerang and a
fun and likable presence miracles do
happen and last on my list of pros Jared
Leto as the Joker I think that he is
doing something really cool I think that
he's doing something very different I
liked his portrayal of the Joker it
wasn't exactly like Nicholson it wasn't
exactly like Ledger it was sort of a
combination of the best of the both and
he also had some really cool visual
things going on with his face and his
outfits there were some good moments
with him and that leads me into my cons
when I said there were some good moments
with the Joker that's absolutely what I
meant he's barely in this movie don't go
to this movie excited about Jared Leto
as the Joker because you're not going to
get much of it his scenes are so minimal
that when I think back on the movie I
can't think of that one scene with the
Joker I can't think of a standout scene
he does not have an interrogation scene
like in the Dark Knight he doesn't have
a hahaha I thought my jokes were bad
scene he has nothing like that
he's just got a couple lines every here
and there scattered throughout the movie
that was a big disappointment for me
because a lot of the marketing kept his
performance very under wraps like it was
this big awesome thing but in reality
they just didn't have that much footage
to work with because he's barely in this
movie the second and third act is a
gigantic city scene just it all just
kind of bleeds together and becomes one
big messy scene I could tell they were
trying to make a more contained film
which I am all for I love contained
movies I love smaller movies that have
big ideas to take place in one small
environment but that claustrophobia just
wasn't there and that feeling of in the
moment real time action just wasn't
there because there
some seriously choppy editing going on
here and a ton of shit was cut out I
know it there has got to be a ton of
deleted scenes on this blu-ray and I am
really curious to find out about that
because there's also a lot of scenes
that do feel very much so tacked on
there's this elevator fight scene with
Harley Quinn that really felt like it
was a reshoot scene from the beginning
of the second act all the way to the
finale it just felt like so much had
been cut out and removed from this movie
to where it was just bare-bones
action sequences and a few conversations
now there was one aspect of this movie
that I was very curious about because it
was kept from almost all marketing and
that is the villain now if you don't
know who the villain of this movie is
and you don't want to know who the
villain of this movie is I'm going to
talk about the villain now I don't
consider it a spoiler but if you don't
want to know who the villain is or my
thoughts on said villain then I will let
you know that I'm about to discuss that
that's my way of respecting you guys the
villain in this movie is in Shan trous
it's this which character who can do all
kinds of crazy things she has a
relationship with one of the people
involved with the Suicide Squad and so
there's some tension there because she's
also this witch enchantress they can
take over people and make them do things
and she turns a random person into
Incubus and this guy just kind of starts
wreaking havoc and she just starts
strutting around and doing like hip
moves and making like weird faces and
twirling her arms around my one friend
said she looked like she was hula
dancing most of the time and I got to
tell you guys straight up there were
aspects of this finale that reminded me
a fan for stick it is that messy at one
point one character is in dire danger
and you're positive this character is
dead things are like tentacles are like
going through this person's body and
shit and like five minutes later this
character just walks on-screen their
clothes are perfect there's no dirt
there's no sweating they're just like
hey what's up yeah I'm fine so in truth
the storytelling here is very poor it's
a very choppy film there are entire
things that just feel ripped out and
left on the cutting-room floor I'm very
curious to see what this blu-ray looks
like and the special features there are
good portrayals of some of these
characters in this movie like the Joker
like Harley Quinn like Deadshot there
are aspects of these characters I really
enjoyed I wanted
way more jared leto because i was
intrigued by what he was doing there are
some good jokes there are some fun
scenes but the action sequences feel
very pedestrian and there doesn't seem
to be anything special about them
there's just a lot of weird shapes
coming out of the sides of the frame and
people slice through them and shoot them
and nothing really happens of much
weight or importance suicide squad was
very disappointing and I'm going to give
it a see so guys I've gotten an absurd
amount of requests to watch Netflix new
show stranger things and I did I just
finished it last night I'm going to
review that for you this weekend and I'm
going to go see Nine Lives
the Kevin Spacey cat movie because I
just want to I just feel like it I'll
see what happens with that one guys
thank you so much as always for watching
I do appreciate it very much and if you
liked this you can click right here and
get steppen eyes